and finally new rule new york city
has to stop exporting its garbage to the
rest of america
the infamous garbage barge the train of
sewage sent to alabama
and worst of all now the city's most
toxic trash has been carted off to
washington d.c
[Music]
no new york is not sending us its best
people
it's a great town but it also breeds a
certain type of
obnoxious in your face meathead that
used to be safely quarantined by the
lack of decent pizza west of the hudson
but now they've gotten loose and taken
over the whole country trump
little trump giuliani
michael cohen the mooch
the mnuchin big personalities colorful
characters guys who eat on the phone
human steamrollers who would man spread
on a life raft
what the heartland used to call [ __ ]
and someone from real america has to
tell me why you like these guys now
how did the salt of the earth people get
hooked up with the salt and the wound
people
it's
it's like watching the country music
awards hosted by andrew dice clay
what happened to your values what
happened to good manners and monogamy
you're the my word is my bond people
these guys lie
just to stay in practice you're all
about an honest day's work trump watches
tv until noon
you're frugal they spend like identity
thieves who got a hold of your pin
number
you're stoic trump's a whiny little
[ __ ]
well here's my theory you didn't like it
that the country had been
taken over by liberals and feminists and
elites whatever
so you were feeling vulnerable and
disrespected so you brought in some
muscle from the east coast for
protection
and now you're married to the mob
because that's what this administration
is
a protection racket that's what freaked
out comey
about trump he had served democrats and
republicans
he never worked for childish gambino
he couldn't believe it when trump said
to him i hope you can let this go
like the health inspector just found a
finger in the linguini
[Applause]
people call this presidency a reality
show it's more like a scorsese movie
everything trump does is modeled on the
mob when he was accused of sexual
harassment he brought in bill clinton's
accusers to sit in the gallery at the
debate
just like michael corleone brought frank
pantengilly's brother
into court who does trump surround
himself with disposable lawyers and
idiot members of his own family
who's his worst enemy the fbi where does
his money come from
he's in construction
forget about it he's so much like a don
his name is literally dawn
what part of this isn't mob like they're
using a legitimate front business
in this case the white house to enrich
the family
he's got a consigliere who says things
like men are disposable but a fine woman
like ivanka
who's writing this dialogue mario putso
women and children they can afford to be
careless
but not men
trump had a personal luca brazzy like
bodyguard
he's got the jew bookkeeper
he's got the up-and-coming good earner
scaramucci who's cut from the same cloth
as the dawn
rayon he's even got the fat guy from new
jersey who keeps around to make himself
look
thin
and joe pesci is the campaign manager
oh and of course fredo
fredo who they send to handle little
things like peace in the middle east
and then there's the muscle end of the
family last week on fox giuliani said
michael cohen did his job he made it go
away
made it go away that's what a fixer does
he makes things go away
that's why cohen always has the look of
a rat that can't get out of the toilet
and i must say as someone who never
liked donald trump even before he got
into politics
his being president has been quite a
revelation i always thought of him as an
egomaniac and a blowhard
but i didn't realize until this very
year that he was a cheap hood
all along a common thug
i never knew that
michael cohen once said to a reporter
tread very [ __ ] lightly cause what
i'm gonna do to you is gonna be [ __ ]
disgusting you understand me
and according to stormy daniels trump
set one of his goons to tell
her hey that's a beautiful little girl
be a shame if something happened to a
mom
this is what you get when you get in bed
with the mob
and maybe that's okay with you maybe you
said to yourself
this is the business we've chosen but i
gotta say if you sold your soul
to get protection from these two
grandmas
the big [ __ ] is you